The job of the Control Plane is to compute
state that ultimately ends up in the data plane.
So computing a forwarding path that satisfies a high-level
policy is something that the Control Plane would do.
The Control Plane can also compute shortest path routing
trees. And it might make decisions about whether or
not a user's device should be allowed to send
traffic or not based on that device's MAC address.
Rate-limiting is something that is typically done
in the data plane, and the load-balancing example
that we have listed here. Is such that a router or a switch would make
decisions in the data plane based on a hash of the source IP address. So
all of the decisions are being made at
forwarding time, not by a centralized high-level program.